mother is directed by Darren Aronofsky
and stars Jennifer Lawrence and Javier
Bardem Ed Harris
Michelle Pfeiffer and someone else who I
won't mention but I was like what when
they appeared that was just so random
you'll see when you see the film this
film is about how Jennifer Lawrence's
character is named mother and Javier
Bardem s character has named him he's
trying to write a poem he's a very
famous poet but he has serious writer's
block she's trying to restore their
idyllic country home a paradise they've
created together to seclude themselves
from everyone else
suddenly a visitor shows up Edie Harris
then later his wife shows up Michelle
Pfeiffer and before she knows that her
entire house is filled with random
strangers and there's a hole in the
floor that's bleeding and the house has
a heart this movie is insane Aronofsky
has crafted a film that will keep people
talking for years and after the movie I
just kind of sat there and watched all
of the credits and it felt like the
movie hadn't ended yet like I was still
watching it now this might sound
negative but I am very much so the
opposite of that
I am very intrigued by this movie it's a
puzzle that I want to put together but I
also infuriatingly know that I never
will because there's a billion different
ways to interpret this movie there are
so many different meetings there's tons
of metaphors and visual imagery that's
meant to inspire conjecture and it's
going to amongst film fans for years
there's biblical references to Cain and
Abel I think there's stuff about the
earth and God and
it's crazy it's crazy it's insane and I
admire it my screening invite for this
film came with 12 pages of press notes
that's unprecedented that's never
happened to me before I didn't read any
of it until I saw the film though and I
went back and I read it and it was
clearly like they were trying to like
lessen the blow of what I was about to
watch by kind of easing me into the
strangeness of this film but still I'm
glad I didn't read it because I was
basically transfixed for the entire
movie by incredible performances from
Lawrence and Bardem in particular very
much so Jennifer Lawrence she is on the
screen for so much of the movie and so
much of it as close-ups or over the
shoulder and that is sometimes a little
bit annoying because I am asking for a
wide I find myself begging for a wide
shot to let me breathe for a second or
experience something else besides the
back of her hair or the front of her
face but you don't get that too often
the camera will follow her for very long
periods of time as she sees frightening
or strange disturbing things the last
half of this movie is absolute insanity
so many things happen that I won't spoil
for you that just had me gripping my
knees like eviscerated by what I was
looking at that's like mentally I just
felt like it was tearing me to pieces
this movie is designed to unsettle
audiences and it will it will also anger
Minnie and it already has there's tons
of people who have done reviews who are
upset with this film who find it very
offensive and feel that there's there's
just a bunch of pretentious imagery and
that's it and I can completely
understand that that's something that
I've certainly felt before when I see
some of these more artsy films but this
one in particular it like invited me to
want to figure it out it made me want to
learn more about what he was trying to
say there's environmental issues that
he's exploring the way we treat the
planet the way we treat each other the
way Fame can have an impact on you and
the ones you care about if you let it
there are so many different ways to
interpret this movie that I hesitate to
say there is one specific way to
pinpoint what Aronofsky is going for
which I
really respect I don't always need to go
to a film and experience 90 to 100
minutes of a movie where I feel like
that was easily digestible and within a
couple hours I'm not thinking about it
anymore
I'm gonna be thinking about this movie
for a very long time I want to research
it it's very intriguing the performances
as I said are staggering the
cinematography is extremely well done
the color and look of this house the way
the wood creaks the way Jennifer
Lawrence is so innocent throughout this
entire film and vulnerable her
performance is so ragged and intense
that it might garner her another Oscar
nomination unless the Academy are like
really prudent about the fact this
movies kind of fucked up which could
happen
I do have an interpretation for what I
think he was going for at least in
regards to the two main characters and
I'm starting to lean that way I won't
talk about it now I'll wait till after
my grade because even though I don't
really consider it a spoiler I know a
lot of my viewers don't want to know
anything going in they just want a very
basic idea of how I feel because spoiler
sucks so after I give my grade I'll talk
a little bit about my interpretation as
for flaws the pacing can really suffer
sometimes because we go from extremely
unsettled and socially awkward
experiences back to normal everyday life
and then the house is making sounds and
people are doing strange things they're
grabbing paint buckets painting her
house for her doing all these really
awkward things that you just don't
understand and it can be a little
maddening actually and that's kind of
what he's trying to do but because it's
so hard on first viewing to really laser
focus on what Aronofsky's trying to say
some scenes can drag because you're like
what is happening right now
on second viewing I feel like that will
improve also I don't want to like get
into conspiracy theory stuff but
Aronofsky in the past has been accused
of pseudo plagiarism with the anime
perfect blue and his film Black Swan
which i think is excellent I do think
perfect blue is better though and with
this film there are some taste
Rosemary's Baby and I feel like some
people will probably pick up on that and
go forth with more plagiarism rumors but
this is definitely its own thing and I
don't consider him plagiarizing
Rosemary's Baby at all but there is
definitely aspects of it that are
similar because of the fact that this is
Aronofsky's brain on fire like
supposedly he wrote this screenplay in
days and then filmed an entire movie at
another set without CG or anything like
that to try to figure out what he was
trying to say then he filmed the actual
movie because this is so many things
crammed into one movie sometimes it can
feel very messy but I do think that it's
worth seeing and I do think it's a
special and unique film that is going to
cause people to talk which is very good
in today's day and age of big
blockbuster movies I'm gonna give mother
and a - this movie is weird okay and
many people are not going to like it
it's incredibly divisive I have friends
who hated it
I mean hated it and I'm sure many others
will and others will say it's a
masterpiece
but there's one thing that this film for
sure is doing causing people to talk
about it
which is rare today so interpretation if
you don't want to know what I think
Jennifer Lawrence's character represents
and what I think hobby of our dams
character represents come back after you
see it I feel like he's trying to say
that Bardem is God and that Lawrence is
Mother Earth she is in constant aw of
Javier Bardem and he is constantly
ignoring her he wants to forgive his
fans for really horrible acts and really
terrible things that they're doing and
she doesn't understand why and I feel
like this is almost Aronofsky getting
out a lot of sort of theological rage
that he might have stored up there was a
lot of different things in this movie
that could hint at that there's Cain and
Abel stuff - with two brothers in the
movie and if you have like a knowledge
of Aronofsky's past I mean obviously he
made Noah so he definitely has a lot of
thought
on religion and the Bible and it feels
like in some ways this movie is
exploding with those ideas now this
could just be my wrong interpretation
but I feel like that is in general if
you could just pinpoint one thing that
that's probably what he was going for
but we'll see check it out I hope you
guys enjoy the film and I hope that it
affects you in some way shape or form
because it certainly did me guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stubborn eyes
[Music]